>>Teacher: We wanted to
welcome you guys to our Books
of Hope Exhibition for 2009.
>>Narrator: YES Prep North Central
is constantly looking for ways
to involve parents in
their child's education.
Like this book fair, a combination
social service project, fundraiser,
and demonstration of student work.
>>Allie: They've written books
to send to a school in Uganda
and it looks like they've chosen
various topics to write about,
and looks like a really good project.
They spent a good deal
of time researching,
a lot of the kids have their
rough drafts available,
so it's nice to see their
process that they went through.
>>Student: I did mine
on musical instruments.
It's called, The String Family.
>>Allie: Knowing that my son is
here at YES Prep, it's excellent.
There's rigor, and
everything is interrelated,
and it's a very small school,
it's very family oriented.
>>Student: And this is
just like a mini-synopsis
on the history of guitars.
>>Allie: I really feel
good and confident
about the education
that he's getting here.
>>Teacher: So it was back there?
>>Narrator: Parents get involved
with YES Prep even before their
kids enroll in the school.
During the summer, students and
staff members visit the homes
of prospective students to deliver a
contract that includes a commitment
on the part of the parents.
>>Oh, come in, please, Sir.
>>Bryan: I think the home
visit does a number of things.
At first, it's that direct personal
contact we can have with the parents,
and I think it's a nice personal
touch that kind of sets the mood
for the fact that we are
a family oriented school.
We're not only willing to say
it, but we're willing to kind
of put our money where our mouth is.
>>Under Student Commitments, can you
go one by one on those bullet points,
and read those out loud for me?
>>The parents absolutely love it,
and to go to these home visits,
it's a great reminder
of why we do what we do.
I've done home visits before, where
parents have just wept, because,
I mean, they truly feel like
they're lucky and they're blessed.
>>Orianno, you know
the Parent Contract?
>>Oh yes, Sir, I got my son, my
daughter already in the school.
>>Bryan: You're a pro.
>>Yes.
>>Chris: The contract, I
think is, it's symbolic,
but what we want parents
to understand is
that this has got to
be a team effort.
You know, this is a
three legged stool.
It's us, it's your kid, and it's
you, and if we work together
for the next seven years, your
kid is going to be able to go
to any college they want to.
>>Bryan: Sign under the
Student Signature, please?
>>Narrator: The written commitment
of parents and students to the goal
of a college education,
comes in handy
when a student wanders off track.
>>Bryan: Because there's no
reason that you should be
in this position right now.
>>Chris: We don't kick kids out,
if the stuff on the
contract doesn't get done.
If stuff on the contract
doesn't get done,
it becomes a teaching opportunity
for the parent or the kid,
to pull that thing
out, and say, look,
this is what you said
you were going to do.
And it's a great reminder, and
it's a great reference point,
when we need to have
these conversations.
>>Student: I don't know,
this year just hasn't--
I don't know where it went.
>>Bryan: When you say that, you
make it sound like the wind.
You are in control
of this year, right?
So it needs to be you,
a book, and this.
>>Student: To start off, my
topic is Business In Fashion.
>>Narrator: Most parent visits
to YES Prep involve presentations
of student accomplishments,
like this personal project.
>>Student: My goal was
to design three pieces,
and then get at least 50 percent of
the tenth grade to actually say, yes,
I would actually wear that.
I got to actually make this,
and I showed it to them.
And they were-- they
thought it was short,
but they were proud of my work.
>>Teacher: What do you
think, Dad, too short?
Definitely.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Allie: So it looks like you have
lots of pictures and text features.
>>Narrator: At the Seventh Grade
Exhibition, hard work pays off,
as the whole class gets to
shine in front of their parents.
>>Katie: We found that exhibitions
are a great way to get parents
to come and see their
child's work, and to be proud
of their child's work, and to
see what we're doing as a school.
Often we try to invite
all of the parents,
just to make the kids feel like,
you know, this was important work
that you did, and that, you know,
people are interested in seeing it.
>>Bonnie: My title, I called
it Math, Easy As 1-2-3,
because it's really easy as 1-2-3.
>>Efrain: I don't see a
lot of commitment for us,
although we're there for her,
but it seems like she's
got it all wrapped up.
>>Bonnie: This page is
dedicated to people in Uganda,
and people that love math like I do.
>>Efrain: She's learning it takes
a lot of hard work, not just 50,
60 percent, it takes
100 percent effort,
and basically that's what it takes
for college, it takes a lot of work,
a lot of sleepless hours.
>>Bonnie: If I want to see what is 6
times 8, I would look at this table,
and see 6, and then
the 8, which is 48.
See, so it's easyk, very easy.
>>Allie: I think that the
teachers here do an excellent job.
They're always available for any
kind of questions that I might have,
as a parent, and also any questions
that my son might have, as a student,
and they're extremely patient.
Yeah, they put this first,
above everything else,
so it's a privilege to
be a YES Prep parent.
>>Efrain: And what grade would be a
good idea to teach this type of math?
>>Bonnie: I would say
third grade, I--
>>Efrain: Bonnie, we're
proud of you, and--
>>Woman: We love the school.
>>Efrain: We love, YES, we
love, YES, definitely YES.
When you go to college,
university, YES.
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.